so start here you can see he's got a
suite of field test weapons these are
guns that you can kind of like lease out
for free that are pretty cool and and
you get you try it you get to try a
suite of different weapons and they're
like weapon bounties that you take the
weapon you equip it you go into the
world you shoot a bunch of monsters you
kill a bunch of stuff and when you've
completed that you earn reputation with
the gunsmith yeah so the first time
that's right so everybody has a gunsmith
zero reputation this is actually
accurate right now makes sense to earn
reputation with a gunsmith you have to
kill things with his guns so with the
gunsmith as you use field test weapons
or you complete quests for him because
he's involved in a lot of the quest
chains he'll increase your done Smith
reputation and what that gets you is
access to these which are the foundry
orders okay so once you hit Rank 1 or
our hunter you can go to ban cheat and
look at the things he has available in a
given week and pick one or two of them
okay so because your rank 0 you can't
accept any right now but once you rank
up and at high ranks you can have more
of them at a time and what an order does
for you is it says when the next arms
day which is on Wednesdays the next
Wednesday that rolls around his delivery
will be here for you and you'll be able
to come and pick up the weapon of the
type that you chose so does this this
coincides with the weekly reset it's the
day after in fact after okay so
wednesday is gonna be new gun day in the
crucible that's right again this is
another deterministic way to get
something sweet and get him you can look
at what he has available and you can
pick the ones that your interests will
be yeah these aren't Engram I'm actually
if I buy this I'm actually going to get
a haka gijinka go go go d okay go ahead
I thought I was printout Tekkit haka
pack actually there's a huge culture war
Bungie right now between you know the
Dutch and the Germans yes so if you
ain't depends on who you ask haka kisses
report or yeah so I don't know I guess
we're just gonna have to have that be
potato invitado in the world of destiny
so i can get and the this the stock will
refresh from week to week yeah every
week he has a different set of orders
available everything conversation point
right like yeah i really hope for arms
day
he has X Y or Z and then of course we've
always had the you know all the
console's tobin consumables telemetry
'he's ammunition so Justin last week you
already you already did this right yeah
actually I have an order ready on my
character so let's check and I can just
go to the gunsmith here and when I
talked to him he'll just pop up here's
my order so my orders arrived it's a
thorough see is 43 scout rifle musket
rifle and I'll just take that weapon you
know go up here and crack that one open
and just like the other the source
regime we are looking at service weapons
they have perks that let you choose and
customize the behavior a little bit more
you know rodeo and then basically like
the service weapons you want to tweak
them to the way you like them sure or I
say I don't like it I'm going to
dismantle it I'm gonna get some marks
and I'm gonna go buy my searles yep yeah
and so there's a talent on this screen
and it's been a lot of screen you've
been avoiding when we talk about that so
this is the infuse the node so all the
year to legendaries and exotics they
have this note on it which is basically
the replacement for ascension for these
year two items and the way infused works
is you can take a weapon like this one
yeah and you know maybe this is my
favorite weapon I really like this one
but it's getting long in the tooth
because I'm getting some red drops that
are higher power and so on well I can
open this up and what infusion lets you
do is say I'm going to take a more
powerful weapon like this 290 here and I
pay some some currencies some parts and
I can consume this weapon to make this
weapon stronger so now this is a 288 and
I can keep walking these weapons or
pieces of armor up and keeping them
current because we're really trying to
deliver on people being able to find
things that they're excited about and
keep them and customize their character
keep them with him this is a destiny
year to feature that's right this is
works on destiny year two weapons that's
right these are either found on all the
year two weapons and all the year to
armor sorry legendary weapons yeah
exotic weapons
jerry armor exotic armor so this allows
me if I if I get a legendary item that i
really like but might be medium level in
terms of its attack or defense and I
like I like the way it looks or I like
the talent combination on it I can
continue to pull this thing forward by
like essentially using other other items
other higher power items as fuel that
you upgrade this thing yet you can you
can use higher level legendaries you can
even use higher level blues if you find
them as fuel to make your legendaries in
yours alter so this is another way it's
going to let people look different in
the end game that's right right was
there like a sacred altar where we can
bring our guns and do like a ritualistic
chant as we sacrifice them to infuse the
guns into other guns well there is a
sacred altar where you'll be storing a
lot of these guns because if you've got
a lot of projects on the go well you
know we're going to keep those things